dans la lutte contre le coc vite 19
voilà une missive qui fait désordre dans
une europe déjà critiqué pour agir en
ordre dispersé dans une lettre adressée
aux instances européennes
les chefs d'état de l'autriche de la
république tchèque de la slovénie de la
bulgarie et de la lettonie alertes sont
les disparités de distribution des
vaccins au sein de murs les livraisons
de doses de vaccin par les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques aux différents états
membres de l'ue eux ne sont pas
effectués de façon équitable
si ce système devait perdurer il
continuerait à créer et à exacerber
d'énormes disparités entre les états
membres d'ici à l'été de sorte que
certains d'entre eux seraient en mesure
d'atteindre l'immunité de groupe en
quelques semaines tandis que d'autres
seraient à la traîne
d'après le chancelier autrichien
sebastian geurts les rapport d'inégalité
irait du simple au triple maman dis à la
sauce armen ceux ci l'on rassemble tous
et qu'on l'analyse il parie que par
exemple malte aurait trois fois plus de
doses de vaccin par habitant que la
bulgarie d'ici la fin juin
philippe raud quand les pays-bas
devraient non seulement obtenir plus de
doses de vaccin par habitant d'ici la
fin juin que leur pays voisins
l'allemagne mais presque deux fois plus
que la croatie et l'autriche est
actuellement au milieu du groupe selon
nos informations ce fils micro atx m la
cause présumée d'une telle disparité
serait à chercher
selon le chancelier autrichien dans un
circuit de négociations parallèles qui
opérerait directement entre les états et
les groupes pharmaceutiques
il y a les indications selon lesquelles
il existait une instance un bazar où des
accords supplémentaires ont été conclus
entre des états membres et des firmes
pharmaceutiques lapointe farmington
émane qui trop fou warning une
accusation démentie par la commission
européenne qui réfute l'existence d'un
tel mécanisme
l'instance rappelle qu'à l'origine elle
avait une préférence pour la répartition
des distributions au prorata de la
population
les états membres ont décidé de
s'écarter de la proposition de la
commission
en ajoutant une flexibilité permettant
de convenir
d'une répartition différente des doses
en tenant compte de la situation
épidémiologique et des besoins de
vaccination de chaque état se serait
désormais aux états membres de trouver
un accord
s'il souhaite revenir à l'attribution au
prorata le ministère autrichien de la
santé a rejeté de son côté les
affirmations de son chancelier assurant
que les négociations avaient lieu de
façon transparente et équilibrée mais
cette accusation désormais porté par
cinq états européens sera discutée lors
du prochain sommet prévu du 25 au 26
mars